welcome to Wilcox County Alabama it's a
rural area with the highest unemployment
estate Wilcox County's the poorest
County in Alabama its 16th course county
in the United States so we're desperate
for jobs jobs are coming back you might
be surprised at who's doing the hiring
Chinese manufacturers consider golden
dragon copper the world's largest
manufacturer of high-grade copper pipe
for HVAC systems we're going to take
these sheets now we're gonna pick it up
with the crane we're going to load it
into this melting furnace the company is
100 million dollar plant just opened
here last May we currently have
approximately 160 US employees and that
will grow to about 300 one more up at
coal production so why would the Chinese
come to Alabama a cheaper dollar for
starters more predictable wages lower
energy costs faster delivery to US
customers and the biggest benefit of all
no import tariffs they have to face a 11
percent uplift in tariffs if the product
is shipped from China or 26 percent if
the product is shipped from the Mexico
factory and now that it has the Alabama
factory zero
that saves how much money in golden
dragon case it could be thirty million
dollars a year for Chinese companies now
operate in the state it's a trend
Alabama governor Bentley used to his
advantage when he entered office back in
2011 he vowed not to take a paycheck
until Alabama returned to full
employment the reason that most
companies come here is we have an
environment that entices companies to
come any time a company comes to Alabama
they say do you have enough workforce
all right is your workforce trained a
IDT is an organization that that does
most of our workforce training on-site
they actually build facilities to train
the workers and and they train them
according to specification of that
industry what's happening in Alabama is
starting to happen across America
Chinese companies invested a record 14
billion dollars in the US last year they
now employ 70,000 Americans on us
well that's up from 10,000 in 2007 we're
on a global economy whether we want to
be or don't want to be did you ever
thought you'd be recruiting Chinese
companies to come to doping elbow
absolutely not